okay let's get started again okay so
welcome back to week three of CS 224 in
okay so we we've got a bit of a change
of pace today after week two so this
week in week 3 we're actually going to
have some human language and so this
lecture has no partial derivative signs
in it and so we'll be moving away from
sort of working out the so
technicalities of doing neural networks
and back propagation and the sort of
math heavy week to and so then this week
what we actually want well in today's
lecture we won't look at well what kind
of structures do human language
sentences have and how we can build
models that build that kind of structure
for sentences that we see so first of
all I'm going to sort of explain and
motivate a bit about structure of human
language sentences so that's kind of
like linguistics in 20 minutes or
something then going to particularly
focus in on dependency grammars and then
going to present a method for doing
dependency structure dependency grammar
parsing called transition based
dependency parsing and then talk about
how you can make neural dependency
parsers so going on just near a couple
of announcements so assignment 2 was do
one minute ago so I hope everyone
succeeded in getting assignment two out
of the way if you still working on it do
make sure to make use of the office
hours and get help for that coming out
just today is assignment three
assignment three is basically about this
lecture so in assignment 3 what you're
doing is building a neural dependency
parser and so we hope that you can put
together what you learned about neural
networks last week and the content of
today and jump straight right in to
building a neural dependency parser
the other thing that happens in
assignment 3 is that we start using a
deep learning framework pi torch so for
doing assignment 3 instruction 0 and
this is in the PDF that the assignment
is to install pi torch as a Python
package and start using that so we've
attempted to make assignment 3 sort of
be a highly scaffolded tutorial where
you can start to learn how to do things
in pi torch by just writing a few lines
of code at a time hopefully that works
out for people if you have any issues
with that well obviously you can send
Piazza messages come to office hours I
mean the one other thing you could think
of doing is that there's sort of a
one-hour introduction to PI torch on the
PI torch site where you down where
you've directed for installing PI torch
and you can also look at that if that
was maybe helpful now the final mentions
yes so final projects you know we're
going to sort of focus on those more in
week 5 but if it's not bad to be
thinking about things you could do if
you want do a custom final project you
know certainly encourage to come and
talk to me or the TAS
we have under the sort of office hours
page on the website a listing of the
expertise of some of the different TAS
since I missed my office hours yesterday
I'm going to have a shortened office
hour tomorrow from 1/2 to 20 that's at
the same time as the normal cs2 24 in
office hours so you can kind of come for
any reason you want but it might be
especially good to come to me if you
want to talk about final projects
okay so let's leap in and start talking
about the structure of sentences and so
I just sort of want to explain something
about human language sentence structure
and how people think about that
structure and what kind of goals then
people and natural language processing
have of sort of building structure to
understand the meaning of sentences all
of the examples I'm going to give today
in
English because that's a language if
you're all expected to have some
competence in but this really isn't
meant to be sort of facts about English
this is meant to be sort of ideas of how
you can think about the structure of
human language sentences that are
applied to all sorts of languages okay
and so in general there are two
different ways that linguists have
thought about the structure of sentences
there there's some relations to them one
of them is called freeze structure or
freeze structure grammar x' and if you
vaguely remember from CS 103 if you did
that when you spent a about a lecture on
context-free grammars phrase structure
grammar czar using the tools of
context-free grammars to put structures
over sentences and so I'm first of all
going to just briefly introduce that so
you've seen it but actually the main
tool that we're going to use in this
class and for assignment 3 is to put
dependency structures over sentences so
I'll then go about that so the idea of
phrase structure is to say the sentences
are built out of units that
progressively nests so we start off with
words that cap cuddly etc and then we're
going to put them into bigger units that
we call phrases like the cuddly cat by
the door and then you can keep on
combining those up into even bigger
phrases like the cub the cat by the door
whoops okay that's that so how does this
work well so the idea of it and this is
sort of the way a linguist thinks is to
say well here's this language which you
know might not be English it might be
Oaxacan or some other language
what kind of structure does it have and
well we could look at lots of sentences
of the language and so the linguist is
going to think well I can see patterns
like duck head our dog the dog a cat etc
so it sort of seems like there's one
word class here which linguists often
refer to as determiners they're also
referred to as articles sometimes in
English and there's another word class
here
nouns and so what I to capture this
pattern here it seems like we can make
this unit that I see all over the place
in language which is made of a
determiner followed by a noun and then
so I'd write a phrase structure grammar
rule ie a context-free grammar role of I
can have a noun phrase that goes to a
determiner and a noun
okay but you know that's not the only
thing that I can see so I can also see
other examples in my language of the
large cat or a barking dog or the cuddly
cat the cuddly dog hmm so that seems
that I need to put a bit more stuff into
my grammar so maybe I can say for my
grammar that a noun phrase goes to a
determiner and then optionally you can
put in an adjective and then you can
have a noun and then I poke around a
little bit further and I can find
examples like the cat in a crate or a
barking dog by the door and I can see
lots of sentences like this and so I
want to put those into my grandma but at
that point I noticed something special
because look here some other things and
these things look a lot like the things
I started off with so it seems like
which sort of having a phrase with the
same expansion potential that's misted
inside this bigger phrase because these
ones can also be expanded right I could
have something like the green door or
something in here so I just want to
capture that in some way so maybe I
could say that a noun phrase goes to a
determiner optionally an adjective and
noun and then a something else which
I'll call a prepositional phrase and
then I'm going to write a second rule
saying that a prepositional phrase goes
to a preposition that's going to be
these words here followed by a noun
phrase and so then I'm reusing
oops I'm reusing my noun phrase that I
defined up here and so then I could
immediately generate other stuff I can
sort of say the cat by the large door or
indeed I could say the cat by the large
crate the cat by the large crate on the
table or something like that because
once I can have a prepositional phrase
includes a noun phrase and a noun phrase
includes a prepositional phrase I've
already got something that I can kind of
recursively go back and forth between
noun phrases and I can make infinitely
big sentence that's right yeah yeah so I
could write something like yeah the cat
by the large crate on the large table by
the door right I can keep on going and
make big sentences and I could say well
I've got I don't have space to fit it on
this slide but I've got an analysis of
this according to my grammar where
that's a noun phrase goes to determine R
now prepositional phrase the
prepositional phrase goes to a
preposition and a noun phrase and this
noun phrase goes to determine our
adjective noun prepositional phrase and
that goes to a preposition and another
noun phrase and I keep on going and I
can produce big sentences okay and you
know that kind of then continues on
because you know I can then start seeing
more bits of grammar so I could say well
I can now talk to the cat and so if I
want to capture this talking to a cat
here well that now means I've got a verb
because words like talk and walk have
herbs and then talk to the cat it seems
like after that could become a
prepositional phrase and so I could
write another rule saying that a verb
phrase goes to a verb followed by a
prepositional phrase and then I can make
more bigger sentences like that and I
could look at more sentences of the
language and start building up this is
these context-free grammar rules to
describe the structure of the language
and that's part of what linguists do and
different languages have different
structures so for example like in this
little grammar I've had and in general
in English what you do what you find is
that prepositional phrases follow the
verb but if you go to a different
language like Chinese what you find is
the prepositional phrases come before
the verb and so we could say okay there
are different rules for Chinese and I
could start writing a context-free
grammar for them okay beauty so that's
the idea of context-free grammars and
actually you know this is the dominant
approach to linguistic structure that
you'll see if you go into a linguistics
class in the Linguistics Department
people make these kind of phrase
structure grammar trees but just to be
contrary no it's not actually just to be
contrary it's because this alternative
approach has been very dominant in
computational linguistics what I'm going
to show you instead is the viewpoint of
dependency structure so the idea of
dependency structure is rather than
having these sort of phrasal categories
like noun phrases and prepositional
phrases and things like that we're going
to directly represent the structure of
sentences by saying how words arguments
or modifiers of other words in a
recursive faction which is sort of
another way of saying how their
dependence of other words so we have a
sentence look in the large crate in the
kitchen by the door and if we want to we
can give these word
words word classes so we can still say
this is a verb and this is a preposition
and this is a determiner and this is an
adjective and this is a noun but to
represent the structure what we're going
to say is well look here is the the root
of this whole sentence so that's where
things start and then well where we're
going to look is in the large crate so
that is a dependent of look and well if
within we have for the crate it's got
some modifiers it's a large crate so
that's a dependent of crate it's a large
crate that's a dependent of crate and in
the system of dependencies I'm going to
show you we've got in as kind of a
modifier of crate in the large crate I
could come back to that well but this
crate has its own modification because
it's a crate in the kitchen so we have
in the kitchen as a modifier of crate
and it's a VAT kitchen in the kitchen
these are dependence of crate and well
then we have this next bit by the door
and as I'll discuss in a minute well
what is the by the door modifying it's
still modifying the crate it's saying
it's a crate by the door okay so that by
the door is also a pin and upgrade and
then we've got this structure of
dependencies coming off of it okay and
so that's then the structure you get may
be drawn a little bit more neatly when I
do it in advance like this and so we
call these things a dependency structure
and so crucially what we're doing here
is that we're sorry I had two different
examples
whoops different examples what we're
doing is saying what what words modify
other words and so that allows us to
sort of understand how the
different parts of the sentence relate
to each other and so overall you know
the let me just so say you know you
might wonder why do we need sentence
structure you know the way language
seems to work when you're talking to
your friends is that you just blabber
something and they understand what
you're saying and what goes on beyond
that is sort of not really accessible to
consciousness but well to be able to
have machines that interpret language
correctly we sort of need to understand
the structure of these sentences because
unless we know what words are arguments
and modifiers of other words we can't
actually work out what sentences mean
and I'll show some examples of that as
to how things go wrong immediately
because actually a lot of the time there
are different possible interpretations
you can have and so in general our goal
is you know up until now we've sort of
looked at the meaning of words right we
did word vectors and we found out words
there were similar meaning and things
like that and you can get somewhere and
human languages with just saying words I
mean you can say hi and friendly and
things like that but you can't get very
far with just words right the way human
beings can express complex ideas and
explain and teach things to each other
is you can put together words to express
more complex meanings and then you can
do that over and over again recursively
to build up more and more complex
meanings so that by the time you're
reading the morning newspaper you know
most sentences a sort of 20-30 words
long and they're saying some complex
meaning like you know over night Senate
Republicans resolved that they would not
do blah blah blah and you understand
that flawlessly by just sort of putting
together those meanings of words and so
we need to be able to know what is
connected to what in order to be able to
do that and one of the ways of seeing
that's important is seeing what can go
wrong okay so here is a newspaper
article San Jose cop kills man with
knife
now this has two meanings and the two
meanings depend on well what you decide
depends on what from you what modifies
what so what are the two meanings
meaning one the cop stabs a guy right so
many one is the cop stabs a guy so what
we've got here is we've got the cops
that are killing so this is what we'll
say is the subject of kill is the cops
and I'll just call them the San Jose
cops here and well there's what they
kill which show the the man is an object
of killing and then well one person is
the the cops using knife to kill the
person and so that's then that this is
modifier and here every complex we call
it an instrumental modifier to say that
the cops are killing people with a knife
that's one possible analysis okay then
there's a second meaningless sentence
can have the second meaning the sentence
can have a no okay the second meaning
the sentence can have is it's the man
has a knife so in that case what we want
to say is well you know it's this word
man and this man has noun modifier which
is sort of saying something that the man
possesses and then this dependency is
the same and it's a man with a knife
okay and so the interpretations of these
sentences that you can get depend on
putting different structures over these
sentences in terms of who is what is
modifying what here's another one that's
just like that one
scientists count whales from space okay
so again this sentence has two possible
structures right that we have the
scientists are the subject that
accounting and the whales are the object
and well one possibility is that this is
how they're doing the count
so that they're counting the whales from
space using something like satellite but
the other possibility is that these
parts are the same this is the subject
and this is the object but these are
whales from space which you know we
could have analyzed as a noun phrase
goes to a noun and a PP in our
constituency grammar but it's dependency
grammar we're saying oh this is now a
modifier of the whales and that they are
whales from space that are starting to
turn up as in the bottom example right
so obviously what you want is this one
is correct and this one is here wrong
and so this choice is referred to as a
prepositional phrase attachment
ambiguity and it's one of the most
common and big you ities in the parsing
of English right so here's our
prepositional phrase from space and so
in general when you have prepositional
phrases and before it you have verbs and
noun phrases or nouns that the
prepositional phrase can modify either
of the things that come beforehand right
and so this is a crucial way in which
human languages are different from
programming languages right in
programming languages we have hard rules
as to how you meant to interpret things
that dangle afterwards right so in
programming languages you have an else
is always construed with the closest if
well if that's not what you want you
have to use parentheses or indentation
or something like that I guess it's
different in Python because you have to
use indentation but if we think of
something like C or a similar language
right if you haven't used braces to
indicate it's just deterministically the
else goes with the closest if but that's
not how human languages are human
languages are this prepositional phrase
can go with anything proceeding and the
hearer is assumed to be smart enough to
work out the right one and you know
that's actually put a large part of why
human communication is so a
efficient rave like we can do such a
good job at communicating with each
other because most of the time we don't
have to see very much and there's this
really smart person on the other end who
can interpret the words that we say in
the right way so that's where if you
want to have artificial intelligence and
smart computers we then start to need to
build language understanding devices who
can also work on that basis that they
can just decide what would be the right
thing for from space to modify and if we
have that working really well we can
then apply it back to programming
languages and you could just not put in
any braces and your programming
languages and the compiler would work
out what you meant okay so this is
prepositional phrase a tetraman it's
sort of seems near maybe not that hard
there but you know it it gets worse I
mean this isn't as fun an example but
it's a real example of a sentence from
The Wall Street Journal actually the
board approved as acquisition by Royal
Trust Co Limited of Toronto for twenty
seven twenty seven dollars a share at
its monthly meeting boring sentence but
what is the structure of this sentence
well you know we've got a verb here and
we've got exactly the same subject and
for this noun object coming after it but
then what happens after that well here
we've got a prepositional phrase here
we've got a prepositional phrase
we've just got to see it for
prepositional phrases in a row and so
well what we want to do is say for each
of these prepositional phrases what they
modify and starting off there are only
two choices the verbum announce a de for
but it's going to get more complicated
as we go in because look there's another
noun here and another noun here and
another noun here and so once we start
getting further in there'll be more
possibilities okay so let's see if we
can work it out so by Royal Trust Co
Limited what's that modifying
right it's the acquisition so it's not
the board approved by Royal Trust Co
limited it's an acquisition by Royal
Trust Co Limited okay so this one is a
dependent of the acquisition okay
now we want to do of Toronto and we have
three choices it could be this this or
this
okay so of Toronto is modifying its
acquisition of Toronto is there another
guess but what of Toronto is modifying
its Royal Trust Co Limited of Toronto so
this of Toronto is a dependent of Royal
Trust Co Limited and Royal Trust Co
Limited right that's this again sort of
this noun phrase so it can also have
modifiers by prepositional phrase okay
for $27 a share is modifying acquisition
right so now we leap right back
oops I'm drawing this wrong now we leap
right back and it's now the acquisition
that's being modified and then finally
we have at its monthly meeting is
modifying right it's a prude yeah it's
approved at its monthly meeting okay
oops I drew that one oops I drew that
one the wrong way round with the arrow
sorry it's ribbing down this way I'm
getting my arrows wrong whoops okay so
that we've got this pattern of how
things are modifying and so actually you
know once you start having a lot of
things that have choices like this you
start having if I want to put an
analysis on to this sentence of to work
out the the right structure I have to
potentially consider an exponential
number
possible structures because I've got
this situation where for the first
prepositional phrase there were two
places that could have modified but the
second prepositional phrase there are
three places that could have modified
for the fourth one there are five places
that could have multiplied that just
sounds like a factorial it's not quite
as bad as a factorial because normally
once you've left back that kind of
closes off the ones in the middle and so
further prepositional phrases have to be
at least as far back in terms of what
they modify and so if you get into this
sort of combinatorics stuff the number
of analyses you get when you get
multiple prepositional phrases is this
sequence called the Catalan numbers but
that's still an exponential series and
it's sort of one that turns up in a lot
of places when they're a tree-like
context so if any of you are doing or
have done CS 228 where you see
triangular triangulation of
probabilistic graphical models and you
ask how many triangulations there are
that's sort of like making a tree over
your variables and that again gives you
the number of them as the Catalan series
okay but so the point is we have end up
with a lot of ambiguities okay so that's
prepositional phrase attachments a lot
of those going on they're far from the
only kind of ambiguities I want to tell
you about a few others
okay shuttle veteran and longtime Nasr
executive Fred Gregory appointed to
board why is this sentence ambiguous one
of the different readings of disciplines
okay right answer so yeah there are two
possibilities right that is either that
there's somebody who's a shuttle veteran
and a longtime
Nasr executive and their name is Fred
Gregory and that they've been appointed
to the board or the other possibility is
that there's a shuttle veteran and
there's a long time nasser executive
fred gregory and both of them have been
appointed to the board and so again we
can start to indicate the structure of
that using our dependencies so we can
either say okay
there's Fred Gregory and then this
person is a shuttle veteran and longtime
antep's
and longtime nester executive or we can
say well we're doing appointment of a
veteran and the longtime there's for
executive reg reg ray and so we can
represent by dependencies these two
different structures okay that's one
that one's not very funny again so so
here's a funnier example that
illustrates the same ambiguity
effectively
so here's president's first physical
doctor no heart cognitive issues so
there isn't actually an explicit
coordination word here but effectively
in in natural language or certainly
English you can use kind of just comma
of sort of list intonation to
effectively act as if it was an and or
an or right so here we have again two
possibilities that either we have issues
and the dependent
the dependencies of the dependencies of
issues is that there are no issues so
that's actually a determine are no
issues and then it's sort of like no
heart or cognitive issues so half is
another dependent it's sort of a noun
compound heart issues and so we refer to
as an independancy and then it's heart
or cognitive so that hard or cognitive
is a conjoined phrase inside of this no
heart or cognitive issues but there's
another possibility which is that the
coordination is at the top level that we
have no heart and cognitive issues and
at that point we've have the cognitive
as an adjective modifier the issues and
the know heart the determiner is just a
modifier of heart and then these are
being conjoined together so hard hazard
as a coordinated dependency of issues
okay that's one one I've got more funny
ones
if student gets hmm okay so what the
person who wrote this intended to have
is that there we here we've got an
adjective modifying ambiguity so the
intended reading was that first is an
adjective or modifier of first hand and
its first hand experience
so the first hand is a modifier of
experience and the job is also a
modifier of experience and then we have
the same kind of subject object reading
on that one but unfortunately this
sentence has a different reading where
you change the modification
relationships
and you have it's the first experience
and it goes like this okay one more
example mutilated body washes up on Rio
beach to be used for Olympics beach
volleyball what water what are the two
and bigger one of the two readings that
you can get to this one okay so we've
got this big phrase that I won't and try
and put a structure over to be used for
Olympic beach volleyball and then you
know this is sort of like a
prepositional phrase attachment
ambiguity but it's this time instead of
it's a prepositional phrase that's being
attached we've now got this big verb
phrase we call it right so that when
you've sort of got most of a sentence
but without any subject to it that's
sort of a verb phrase to be used for
Olympic beach volleyball which might be
then finit of form sometimes it's in
participial form like being used for
beach volleyball and really those kind
of verb phrases are sort of just like
prepositional phrases whenever they
appear towards the right end of
sentences they can modify various things
like verbs or nouns so here we have two
possibilities so this to be used for
Olympics beach volleyball what the right
answer is meant to be is that that is a
dependent of the Rio beach so it's a
modifier of the Rio beach but the funny
reading is that instead of that we can
have here's another noun phrase muta
mutilated body and it's the mutilated
body that's going to be used and so then
this would be a noun phrase modifier
love that okay so knowing the right
structure of sentences is important to
understand the interpretations you're
meant to get and the interpretations
you're not meant to get
okay but it's it's sort of okay you know
us using funny examples for the obvious
reason but you know this is sort of
essential to all the things that we'd
like to get out of language most of the
time so you know this is back to the
kind of boring stuff that we often work
with are reading through biomedical
research articles and trying to extract
facts about protein-protein interactions
from them or something like that so you
know this is the results demonstrated
that Chi C interacts rhythmically with
sass a cut Chi a and Chi B and well
whoops turn those notifications off so
if we want to get out sort of
protein-protein interaction facts you
know well we have this Chi see there's
interacting with these other proteins
over there and well the way we can do
that is looking at patterns and our
dependency analysis and so that we can
sort of see this repeated pattern where
you have the noun subject here interacts
with and now modifier and then it's
going to be these things that are
beneath that of the sass a and it's
conjoined things Calle and Chi B are the
things that interacts with so we can
kind of think of these two things as
essentially patterns oops I actually
miss editor this sorry this should also
be involved with whoops we can kind of
think of these two things as sort of
patterns and dependencies that we could
look for to find examples of just
protein protein interactions that appear
in biomedical texts okay so that's the
general idea of what we want to do and
so the tool we want to do it with is
these dependency grammars and so I've
sort of shown you some dependency
grammars I just want to sort of motivate
dependency grammar a bit more formally
and
right so dependency grammar postulates
of what a syntactic structure is is that
you have relations between lexical items
that are sort of binary asymmetric
relations which we draw as arrows
because they're binary and asymmetric
and we call dependencies and there's
sort of two ways common ways of writing
them and I've sort of shown both now one
way is you sort of put the words in a
line and that makes it easier to see the
whole sentence and you draw those sort
of loopy arrows above them and the other
way is you sort of more represented as a
tree where you put the head of the whole
sentence at the top submitted and then
you say the dependents of submitted our
bills were and brown back and then you
say the dependents of each of those so
it was bills on ports and immigration so
they're dependents of bills and were
submitted whereas at the pin of
submitted and you're giving this kind of
tree structure okay so in addition to
the arrows commonly what we do is we put
and type on each arrow which says what
grammatical relations holding them
between them so is this the subject of
the sentence is that the object of the
verb is it a conjunct and things like
that we have a system of dependency
labels so for the assignment what we're
going to do is use Universal
dependencies which I'll show you more a
little bit more of in a minute and if
you think man this stuff is fascinating
I want to learn all about these linguist
structures there's a universal
dependency side that you go can go off
and look at and learn all about them but
if you don't think that's fascinating
for what we're doing for this class
we're never going to make use of these
labels all we're doing is making use of
the arrows and for the arrows you should
be able to interpret things like
prepositional phrases as to what they're
modifying just in terms of where the
prepositional phrases are connected and
whether that's right or wrong okay yes
so formally when we
this kind of dependency grammar we've
sort of drawing these arrows and we sort
of refer to the thing at this end as the
head of a dependency and the thing at
this end as the dependent of the
dependency and as in these examples our
normal expectation and what our parses
are going to do is the dependencies form
a tree so it's a connected acyclic
single rooted graph at the end of the
day
okay so dependency grammar has an
enormous lee long history so basically
the famous first linguist that human
beings know about is parney who wrote in
the 5th century before the Common Era
and tried to describe the structure of
sanskrit and a lot of what parney did
was working out things about all of the
morphology of Sanskrit that I'm not
going to touch at the moment but beyond
that he started trying to describe this
the structure of Sanskrit sentences and
the notation was sort of different but
essentially the mechanism he used for
describing the structure of Sanskrit was
dependencies of sort of working out
these what our arguments and modifiers
of what relationships like we've been
looking at and indeed if you look at
kind of the history of humankind
most of attempts to understand the
structure of human languages are
essentially dependency grammars so sort
of in the later parts of the first
millennium there was a ton of work by
Arabic grammarians and essentially what
they used is also kind of basically a
dependency grammar so compared to that
you know the idea of context-free
grammars and phrase structure grammar z'
is incredibly incredibly new I mean you
can basically totally date at there was
this guy Wells in 1947 who first
proposed this idea of having these
constituents and phrase structure
grammar x' and where it then became
really famous is through the work of
Chomsky which love him or hate him is by
far the most famous linguist and also
variously contributed to computer
science who's heard of the Chomsky
hierarchy do people remember that 103
yeah okay the Chomsky hierarchy the
Chomsky hierarchy was not invented to
torture beginning computer science
students the Chomsky hierarchy was
invented because Chomsky wanted to make
arguments as to what the complexity of
human languages was okay yeah so in
modern work
there's this guy Lucien ten year and he
sort of formalized the kind of version
of dependency grammar that I've been
showing you and so we sort of often talk
about his work and you know it's it's
long term being influential and
computational linguistics some of the
earliest parsing work in us
computational linguistics was dependency
grammars but I won't go on about that
more now okay just one two little things
to note I mean if you somehow start
looking at other papers where there are
dependency grammars people aren't
consistent on which way to have the
arrows point there are sort of two ways
of thinking about this that you can
either think okay I'm going to start at
the head and point to the dependent or
you can say I'm going to start at the
dependent and say what his head is and
you find both of them the way we're
going to do it in this class is to do it
the way ten year did it which was you
start at the head and pointed to the
dependent well sorry
I'm drawing that wrong whoops because
discussion of the outstanding issue so
really the dependent of is discussion
okay but we go from heads to dependents
and usually it's convenient to serve in
addition to the sentence to sort of have
a fake root node that points to the head
of the whole sentence and so we use that
as well okay so to build dependency
parsers or to indeed build any kind of
human language structure finders
including kind of constituency grammar
parsers the central tool in recent work
where recent work kind of means the last
25 years has been this idea of tree
banks and the idea of tree banks is to
say we are going to get human beings to
sit around and put grammatical structure
over sentences and so here are some
examples I'm showing you from universal
dependencies where here are some English
sentences I think miramar was the famous
goat trainer or something and some human
being has sat and put a dependency
structure over this sentence and all the
rest and with the name Universal
dependencies this is just an aside
Universal dependencies is actually a
project I've been strongly involved with
but precisely what the goal of universal
dependencies was is to say what we'd
like to do is have a uniform parallel
system of dependency description which
could be used for any human language so
if you go to the universal dependencies
website it's not only about English you
can find Universal dependency analyses
of no French or German or Finnish or
Kasich or Indonesia and lots of
languages of course there are even more
languages which there aren't Universal
dependencies analyses of so if you have
a big calling to say I'm going to build
a Swahili Universal dependencies tree
bank you can get in touch there anyway
so this is the idea of tree banks and
you know historically tree banks wasn't
something that people thought of
immediately this is such an idea that
took quite a long time to develop right
that people started thinking about
grammars of languages even in modern
times in the 50s and people started
building
four languages in the 1919 60s and so
there's decades of work in the 60s 70s
80s and no one had tree banks the way
people did this work is that they wrote
grammars that they either wrote grammars
like the one I did for constituency of
noun phrase goes determiner optional
adjective noun noun goes to goat or the
equivalent kind of grammars in a
dependency format and they hand-built
these grammars and then train had
parsers that could parse these sentences
and going into things having a human
being
writer grammar feels more efficient
because if you write a rule like noun
phrase goes to terminal optional
adjective noun I mean that that
describes a huge number of phrases
watching an infinite number of phrases
so that you know this is the structure
of you know the cat the dog a cat our
dog a large dog all those things we saw
at the beginning so it's really
efficient you're capturing lots of stuff
with one rule but it sort of turned out
that in practice that wasn't such a good
idea and it turned out to be much better
to have these kind of tree banks
supporting structures over sentences and
it's sort of a bit more subtle as to why
that is because it sounds like pretty
menial work building tree banks and in
some sense it is but you know it turns
out to be much more useful I mean so one
huge benefit is that tree banks are very
reusable that effectively what there was
in 60s 70s and 80s was that every
different NOP person who said about
building a parser invented their own
notation for grammar rules which got
more and more complex and it was only
used by their parser and nobody else's
parser and so there was no sharing and
reuse of the work that was done by human
beings well once you have a tree bank
it's reusable for all sorts of purposes
that lots of people build parsers from
it but also other people use it as well
like linguist
now often use tree banks to find
examples of different constructions but
beyond that this sort of just became
necessary once we wanted to do machine
learning so if we want to do machine
learning we want to have data that we
can build models on and in particular a
lot of what our machine learning models
exploit is how common are different
structures and so we want to know about
the Communists and the frequency of
things but then tree banks gave us
another big thing which is well lots of
sentences are ambiguous and what we want
to do is build models that find the
right structure for sentences and if all
you do is have a grammar you have no way
of telling what is the right structure
for ambiguous sentences or you can do is
say hey that sentence with four
prepositional phrases after it that I
showed you earlier it has 14 different
parcels let me show you all of them but
once you have tree Bank examples you can
say this is the right structure for this
sentence in context and so you should be
building a machine learning model which
will recover that structure and if you
don't that you're wrong okay so that's
tree banks so how are we going to do
build dependency parsers well somehow we
want models that can kind of capture
what's the right path and just think
about abstractly you know there's sort
of different things that we can pay
attention to so one thing that we can
pay attention to is the sort of actual
words right discussion of issues that's
a reasonable thing so it's reasonable to
have issues as a dependent of discussion
where you know discussion of outstanding
that sounds weird so you probably don't
want that dependency there's a question
of how far apart words are most
dependencies a fairly short distance
they're not all of them are and there's
a question of what's in between if
there's a semicolon in between there
probably isn't a dependency across herb
and the other issue is sort of how many
arguments two things take so here we
have was completed if you see the word
was completed you sort of expect that
there'll be a subject before it if
something was completed and it'd be
wrong if there wasn't so you expecting
an argument on that side but on the
other side hand it won't have an object
after it you won't say the discussion
was completed the goat that's not a good
sentence right so you won't have a an
object after it so there's sort of
information of that sort and we want to
have our dependency parsers be able to
make use of that structure okay so
effectively what we do when we build a
dependency parser is we're going to say
for each word is is going to be the
dependent of some other word or the root
so this give here is actually the head
of the sentence so it's the dependent of
root the torque is a dependent of gear
is a dependent of torque and so for each
word we want to choose what is a
dependent of and we want to do it in
such a way that the dependencies form a
tree so that means it would be a bad
idea if we made a cycle so if we sort of
said bootstrapping was a dependent of
torque but then we had things sort of
move around so this goes to here but
then talks a dependent of that as all in
a cycle that's bad news we don't want an
cycles we want a tree and there's one
final issue which is we don't want
things that is to whether we want to
allow dependencies to cross or not and
this is an example of this so most of
the time dependencies don't cross each
other but sometimes they do and this
example here is actually an instance for
that so I'll give a talk tomorrow
on bootstrapping so we're giving a talk
that's the object and when it's being
given is tomorrow but this talk has a
modifier that's on bootstrapping so we
actually have another dependency here
that crosses that dependency and that's
sort of rare that doesn't happen a ton
in English but it happens sometimes in
some structures like that and so this is
the question of whether what we say is
that as the part of a sentence is
projective if there are no crossing
dependencies and there's non projective
if there are crossing dependencies and
most of the time English is projective
and it's parses of sentences but
occasionally not and when it's not as
when you kind of have these constituents
that are delayed to the end of the
sentence right you could have said I'll
give a talk on bootstrapping tomorrow
and then it'd be have a projective pars
but if you want to you can kind of delay
that extra modifier and say I'll give a
talk tomorrow on bootstrapping and then
the parse becomes non projective okay so
that's that there are various ways of
doing dependency parsing but basically
what I'm going to tell you about today
is this one called transition based or
deterministic dependency parsing and
this is the one that's just been
enormous ly influential in practical
deployments of parsing so when Google
goes off and parses every web page what
they're using is a transition based
parser and so this was a notion of
parsing that was mainly popularized by
this guy Wacom Neve ray is a Swedish
computational linguist and what you do
is it's sort of inspired by shift reduce
parsing so probably in you know see s103
your compilers class or something you
saw a little bit of shift reduce parsing
and this is sort of like a shift reduce
parser apart from when we reduce we
build dependencies instead of
constituents
and this has a lot of very technical
description that doesn't help you at all
to look at in terms of understanding
what shift reduce parser does and here's
a formal description of a transition
based shift reduce parsing which also
doesn't help you at all so instead we
kind of look at this example because
that will hopefully help you so what I
want to do is parse the sentence I ate
fish and you know formally what I have
is I have a way I start there are three
actions I can take and I have a finished
condition for formal pars pars and so
here's what I do so I have a stack which
is on this side and I have a buffer so
the stack is what I have built and the
buffer is all the words in the sentence
I haven't dealt with yet so I start the
pars and that's this sort of instruction
here by putting route my route for my
whole sentence onto my stack and my
buffer is the whole sentence and I
haven't found any dependencies yet okay
and so then the actions I can take is to
shift things onto the stack or to do the
equivalent of a reduce where I build
dependencies so starting off I can't
build a dependency because I only have
route on the stack so the only thing I
can do is shift so I can shift I on to
the stack now I could at this point say
let's build a dependency I as a
dependent of route but that would be the
wrong analysis because really the head
of this sentence is 8 so I'm a clever
boy and I shift again and now I have
route I 8 on the stack ok and so at this
point I'm in a position where hey what
I'm gonna do is reductions that build
structure because look I have I ate here
and I want to be able to say that I is
the subject of dependency of 8 and I
will do that by or by doing a reduction
and so what I'm going to do
is the left arc reduction which says
look I'm gonna treat the second from top
thing on the stack as a dependent of the
thing that's on top of the stack and so
I do that and so when I do that I create
the second from the head thing as a
subject dependent of eight and I leave
the head on the stack eight but I sort
of add this dependencies or the
dependencies I've built okay so I do
that now I could immediately reduce
again and say eight is a dependent of
root but my sentence is actually I ate
fish so what I want to do is say oh
there's still fish on the buffer so what
I should first do is shift again have
root eight fish in my sentence and then
I'll be able to say look I want to now
build the thing on the top of the stack
as a write dependent of the thing that's
second from top of the stack and so
that's referred to as a right arc move
and so I say right arc and sorry do a
reduction where I've generated a new
dependency and I take the two things
that are on top of the stack and say
fish is a dependent of eight and so
therefore I just keep the head I always
just keep the head on the stack and and
I generate this new arc and so at this
point I'm in the same position I want to
say that this eight is a write dependent
of my root and so I'm again going to do
right arc and make this extra dependency
here
okay so then my finished condition for
having successfully passed the sentence
is my buffer is empty and I just have
root left on my stack because that's
what I sort of said back here that was
buffer is empty is my finished condition
okay so I've passed the sentence so that
worked well but you know I actually had
different choices of when to park when
to shift and when to reduce and I just
miraculously made
the right choice at each point and well
one thing you could do at this point is
say well you could have explored every
choice and seen what happened and gone
different parses and I could have but if
that's what I'd done I would have
explored this exponential size tree of
different possible parses and if that
was what I was doing I wouldn't be able
to pass efficiently and indeed that's
not what people did in the 60s 70s and
80s clever people in the 60s said how
rather than doing a crummy search here
we can come up with clever dynamic
programming algorithms and you can
relatively efficiently explore the space
of all possible parses and that was sort
of the mainstay of parsing in those
decades but when y came nefra came along
he said yeah that's true but hey I've
got a clever idea because now it's the
2000s and I know machine learning so
what I could do instead is say I'm at a
particular position in the pars and I'm
gonna build a machine learning
classifier and that machine learning
classifier is going to tell me the next
thing to do it's going to tell me
whether the shift will left our core
right arc so if we're only just sort of
talking about how to build the arrows
they're just three actions shift left
our core right arc if we're also wanting
to put labels on the dependencies and we
have our different labels there are then
sort of to our +1 actions because she
sort of left arc subject or left ugh
object or something like that but anyway
there's a set of actions and so you're
going to build a classifier with machine
learning somehow which will predict the
right action and Wykeham me very showed
the sort of slightly surprising fact
that actually you could predict the
correct action to take with high
accuracy so
in the simplest version of this there's
absolutely no search you just run a
classifier at each step and it says what
you should do next is shift and you
shift and then it says what you should
do is left ah can you left arc and you
run that through and he proved wrong he
showed empirically that even doing that
you could pass sentences with high
accuracy now if you want to do some
searching around you can do a bit better
but it's not necessary and we're not
going to do it for our assignment but so
if you're doing this just sort of run
classifier predict action run classifier
but dict action we then get this
wonderful result which you're meant to
explain a bit honest home the assignment
3 is that what we've built is a linear
time parser right because we're going to
be sort of as we chug through a sentence
we're only doing a linear amount of work
for each word and that was sort of an
enormous breakthrough because although
people in the sixties have come up with
these dynamic programming algorithms
dynamic programming algorithms for
sentences were always cubic or worse and
that's not very good if you don't pass
the whole web whereas if you have
something that's linear time that's
really getting you places ok so this is
the conventional way in which this was
done was you know we have a stack we
might have already built some structure
working out something's dependent of
something we have a buffer of words that
we don't deal with and we want to
predict the next action so the
conventional way to do this is to say
well we want to have features and well
the kind of features you wanted was so
usually some kind of conjunction and
multiple things so that if the top word
of the stack is good and something else
is true right that the second toss stop
word of the stack is has and it's part
of speeches verb then maybe that's an
indicator of do some action so here it
had these very complex binary indicator
features and you'd build and you
literally have millions of these binary
indicator fee
and you'd feed them into some big
logistic regression or support vector
machine or something like that
and you would build parsers and these
parses work pretty well but you sort of
had these sort of very complex hand
engineered binary features so in the
last bit of lecture I want to show you
what people have done in the neural
dependency parsing world but before I do
that let me just explain how you how you
evaluate dependency parsers and that's
actually very simple right so what you
do is well you assume because the human
wrote it down that there's a correct
dependency parse for a sentence she saw
the video lecture like this and so these
are the correct arcs and to evaluate our
dependency parser we're simply going to
say which arcs are correct so there are
the gold arcs so there's a gold arc from
two to one she saw subject and there's a
gold arc from 0 to 2 the route of the
sentence these the gold arcs if we
generate a parse and we're going to
propose some arcs as to what is the head
of each word and we're simply going to
count up how many of them are correct
treating each arc individually and there
are two ways we can do that we can
either as we're going to do ignore the
labels and that's then referred to as
the unlabeled attachments score so here
in my example my dependency parser got
most of the arcs right but it got this
one wrong so I say my unlabeled
attachment score is 80% or you can also
look at the labels and then if my parser
wasn't very good at getting the labels
right so I'm only getting 40% and so we
can just count up the number of
dependencies and how many we get correct
and that's our accuracy and in the
assignment you're meant to build a
dependency parser with a certain
accuracy
I forget the number now we're saying
some number 80s something or something
as you're meant to get to okay maybe
I'll skip that okay so now I want to
sort of explain to you just a bit about
neural dependency parsers and why they
are motivated so I mentioned to you
already that the conventional model had
these sort of indicator features of on
the top of the stack is the word good
and the second thing on the stack is the
verb has or on the top of the stack is
some other word and the second top is of
some part of speech and that part of
speech has already been joined at the
dependency of another power of speech
people hand engineer these features and
the problems with that was these
features were very sparse each of these
features matches very few things they
matched some configurations but not
others so the features tend to be
incomplete and there are a lot of them
there are commonly millions of features
and so it turned out that actually
computing these features was just
expensive so that you had some
configuration on your second the buffer
and then you wanted to know which of
these features were active for that
stack and buffer configuration and so
you had to compute features from it and
it turned out that conventional
dependency parsers spent most of their
time computing features that went into
the machine learning model rather than
doing the sort of shifting and reducing
of just a pure parser operation and so
that seemed like it left open the
possibility that well what if we could
get rid of all of this stuff and we can
run a neural network directly on the
stack and buffer configuration then
maybe that would allow us to build a
dependency parser which was faster and
suffered less from issues of sparseness
and a conventional dependency parser and
so that was a project that don t churn
and me tried to do in 2014 mr build and
new
all dependency parser and you know
effectively what we found is that that's
exactly what you could do so here are
sort of a few steps here so these are
these same UAS and la s so mod Parsa was
working near Esparza that I sort of were
so showing before and if got a UAS on
this data of eighty nine point eight but
everybody loved it and the reason they
loved it is it could pass at four
hundred sixty nine sentences a second
there had been other people that worked
out different more complex ways of doing
parsing with so-called graph based
dependency parsers so this is another
famous dependency parser from the 90s so
it was actually you know a bit more
accurate but it was a bit more accurate
at the at the cost of being two orders
of magnitude slower and you know people
have worked on top of that so here's an
an even more complex graph based parser
from the 2000s and well you know it's a
little bit more accurate again but it's
gone even slower okay so what we were
able to show is that using the idea of
instead using a neural network to make
the decisions of Wykeham neveress style
shift reduce parser we could produce
something that was almost as accurate as
the very best parsers available at that
time I mean strictly we won over here
and we were a fraction behind on UAS but
you know it was not only just as fast as
never Esparza it was actually faster
than ever Esparza because we didn't have
to spend as much time on feature
computation and that's actually almost a
surprising result right it's not that we
didn't have to do anything we had to do
matrix multiplies in our neural network
but it turned out you could do the
matrix multiplies more quickly than the
feature computation that he was doing
even though at the end of the day it was
sort of
up weights that went into a support
vector machine so that was kind of cool
and so the secret was we're going to
make use of distributed representations
like we've already seen for words so for
each word we're going to represent it as
a word embedding like we've already seen
and in particular we are going to make
use of word vectors and use them as they
represent the starting representations
of words in our parser but well if we're
interested in distributed
representations it seemed to us like
maybe you should only have distributed
representations of words maybe it'd also
be good to have distributed
representations of other things so we
had parts of speech like you know nouns
and verbs and adjectives and so on well
some of those parts of speech have more
to do with each other than others I mean
in particular most NLP work uses
fine-grain parts of speech so you don't
only have a part of speech like noun or
verb you have parts of speech like
singular noun versus plural noun and you
have different parts of speech for you
know work works working kind of the
different forms of verbs are given
different parts of speech as well so
there are sort of sets of parts of
speech labels that kind of clusters so
maybe we could have distributed
representations apart speech then
represent their similarity why not well
if we're going to do that why not just
keep on going and say the dependency
labels they also have a distributed
representation and so we built a
representation that did that so the idea
is that we have in our stack the sort of
the top positions of the stack the first
positions of the buffer and for each of
those positions we have a word and a
part of speech and if we've already
built structure as here we kind of know
about dependency that's already been
built and so we've got a triple for each
position and we're going to
convert all of those into a distributed
representation which we are learning and
we're going to use those distributed
representations to build our parser okay
now for so you know starting from
starting from the next lecture forward
we're going to sort of start using more
complex forms of neural models but for
this model we did it in a sort of a very
simple straightforward way we said well
we could just use exactly the same model
exactly the same parse of structure that
never used right doing those shifts and
left arcs and right arcs the only part
we're going to turn into a neural
network is we're going to have the
decision of what to do next
being controlled by our neural network
so our neural network is just a very
simple classifier of the kind that we
were talking about last week so based on
the configuration we create an input
layer which means we sort of taking the
stuff in these boxes and turn and
looking up a vector representation for
each one and concatenating them together
to produce a input representation that's
sort of similar to when we were making
those would window classifiers and we
can concatenate it a bunch of stuff
together so that gives us an our input
layer so from there we put things
through a hidden layer just like last
week we do W X plus B and then put it
through a rel your non-linearity to a
hidden layer and then on top of that
we're simply gonna stick a soft max
output layer so we're multiplying by
another matrix adding another bias term
and then that goes into the soft max
which is going to give a probability
over our actions as to whether shift
left our core right arc or the
corresponding one with labels and then
we're going to use the same kind of
cross entropy loss to say how good
job did we do at guessing the action
that we should have taken according to
the tree Bank powers of the sentence and
so each step of the shift reduce parser
we're making a decision of what to do
next and we're doing it by this
classifier and we're getting a loss to
the extent that we don't give
probability one to the right action and
so that's what we did using the tree
Bank we trained up our parser and it was
then able to predict the sentences and
the cool thing the cool thing was that
this had all the good things of never
Esparza but you know by having it use
these dense representations it meant
that we could get greater accuracy and
speed than near Esparza at the same time
so here are sort of some results on that
I mean I already showed you some earlier
results right so this was showing the
fact that you know we're outperforming
these earlier parsers basically but
subsequent to us doing this work people
at Google these papers here
by Weiss and and/or they said well this
is pretty cool maybe we can get the
numbers even better if we make our
neural network bigger and deeper and we
spend a lot more time tuning our hyper
parameters sad but true all of these
things help when you're building neural
networks and when you're doing your
final project sometimes the answers and
making the results better is to make it
bigger deeper and spend more time tuning
the hyper parameters they put in beam
search as I sort of mentioned beam
search can really help so in beam search
you know rather than just saying let's
work out what's the best next action do
that one and repeat over you allow
yourself to do a little bit of search
you sort of say let's consider two
actions and explore what happens
humans always agreed on how to build
these trees and if they don't work
accurately or agreement of humans so
that's a good question which I haven't
addressed humans don't always agree
there are sort of two reasons they can't
agree fundamentally one is that the
humans sort of mess up right because
human work is doing this aren't perfect
and the other one is they genuinely
think that there should be different
structures so you know it depends varies
depending on the circumstances and so on
if you just get humans to parse
sentences and say well what is the
agreement and what they produced you
know maybe you're only getting something
like 92% but you know if you then do an
adjudication phase and you say look at
these differences is one of them right
or wrong there are a lot of them where
you know one of person is effectively
saying are year I goofed
I wasn't paying attention or whatever
and so then what's the residual rate in
which people actually disagree about
possible parses I think that's sort of
more around three percent yeah but there
certainly are cases and that includes
some of the prepositional phrase
attachment ambiguities sometimes there
are multiple attachments that sort of
seem plausible was not really clear
which one is right even though there are
lots of other circumstances where one of
them is very clearly wrong yeah there's
there's still room to do better I mean
at the under labeled attachment score
it's actually Stein get pretty good but
there's still room to do better yeah
yeah so beam search a final thing that
they did was that we're not going to
talk about here is this sort of more
global inference to make sure it's
sensible and so that then led to Google
developing these models that they gave
silly names to especially the Parsee
macaws face model of parsing and so yeah
so that then that sort of pushed up the
numbers even further so that they were
sort of getting close to
ninety-five percent unlabeled accuracy
score from these models and actually is
this workers kind of you know deep
learning people like to optimize this
work has continued along in the
intervening two years and the numbers
are soaking a bit higher again but you
know so this actually led to sort of a
new era of sort of better parsers
because sort of effectively this was the
90s the 90s era of parsers that was sort
of we're around ninety percent and then
going into this sort of new generation
of neural transition based dependency
parsers we sort of have gone down that
we've halved that error error rate and
we're now down to sort of about a five
percent error rate yeah I'm basically
out of time now but you know there is
full of the work including here at
Stanford another student Tim Dozier has
some sort of more recent work that's
more accurate than 95 percent right so
it was still going on but I think I'd
better stop here today and that's neural
dependency parsing